well guys the burger king is dead long
live
the burger king well not quite after
almost
seven years with tsm the great dane
bjergsen himself
is set to leave the mid lane forever and
take up his
new role as tsm's head coach if it goes
well
he could become even more of a legend if
it goes
badly though it could tarnish his legacy
forever
bjergsen has made his decision but is it
really the right move
[Music]
all right then guys before we get into
this one i just want to point you very
quickly to the subscribe button make
sure you are subscribed
leave us a comment if you have any good
ideas for future videos on the channel
and you can also contact us at tips at
the score dot com
less than eight weeks ago bjergsen led
tsm to their seventh
lcs title he seemed unstoppable
it looked like he was back on the north
american throne
after two years of wandering through
lackluster rosters
and dwindling expectations but let's be
honest here for a moment tsm
was soundly crushed at worlds flying
home
without a single win under their belt
but other than the severity of the
losses
nobody was too surprised they didn't
make it out of groups
it seemed like business as usual for
most n a fans and so business
was expected to continue as normal into
the offseason
and beyond not for bjergsen though
he dropped a bombshell in a tsm
announcement video
on saturday i'm here to talk about the
fact that i'm retiring as a professional
player and stepping into the head coach
role for tsm so the end to his playing
career
might actually be the biggest news of
the lcs off-season
and the north american teams at worlds
have like barely finished unpacking yet
looking at people's reactions so far
we've seen shock we've seen
accolades and we've seen a whole bunch
of well wishing and don't get me wrong
this guy seriously deserves it some
pretty big names in the scene have been
very quick to show their support for him
names including yamato cannon loco doco
and
even doublelift himself i think he's
going to do
a great job i think bjergsen is gonna be
an amazing coach i think he'll make a
great coach i
i'm really looking forward to working
with him because
i know he's really smart about the game
and he's really committed this could
prove to be
a genius move but make no mistake here
it is a calculated risk but before
we get into talking about how this could
all go wrong
let's look at why this could be a big
brain
move bjergsen is a leader we all know it
being the de facto captain of tsm means
that his leadership skills should be
transferrable to the coaching
role he knows how to rally a team
around him he's at his back against the
wall
countless times and he's always come out
swinging
dive coming through tp's going to show
up can dignitas actually go for this
dardoch is underneath the turret but now
he's going to be dear oh no
dignitas everything goes wrong and i
mean everything to have this kind of
experience in a coach
is honestly invaluable to be able to
relate to his players like this to know
what it's like to play on the biggest
stages in the world and to have felt
exactly what they're feeling bjergsen
has an almost encyclopedic level
of game knowledge and more importantly
the ability to impart that to others
as well time and time again we've heard
from bjergsen's teammates that
he's not only really really good at the
game he's a natural
teacher too on top of that jerkson could
be a real draw
for top talent look you could be the
best coach
in the whole world but if you don't have
the right talent it ain't gonna work
bjergsen could draw the best in the
business to tsm
simply by virtue of his name and i don't
just mean the players either i'm talking
gm's i'm talking assistant coaches role
coaches
the lot before a prospective player ever
gets to throw on a team jersey and see
what
playing for a team is actually like all
they have to go on
is a team's good name and their legacy
and bjergsen will have that
in abundance okay so talking like this
it's easy to get carried away at least
for me and see this
as a move with zero downsides at all
but the question is is bjergsen really
ready for this sure playing experience
goes a long way but it's not
the one and only thing that makes a good
coach you only have to look at
traditional sports to see
proof of this wayne gretzky for example
the great one
he couldn't pass on his greatness to the
phoenix coyotes
no matter how hard he tried magic
johnson had a
brief but pretty dismal stint coaching
the lakers before he threw in the towel
and even then
it's not just any old team he's taking
the reins of it's the exact same team
he was just on that means it's the exact
same
people but now with very different work
relationships
and that brings us very nicely to the
absolute elephant in the room
bjergsen is set to become doublelift's
coach an authoritative figure to him
whichever way you look at it
they've been friends they've been rivals
they've been teammates they've been
a lot of different things to each other
over the years but they've never had
this dynamic
and doublelift even said on the stream
that he actually considered retiring
when
he heard the news i was like writing my
retirement speech
for a few days and uh i was thinking
about wow it's crazy you know if me and
soren both retire how crazy is that
going to be for lcs
now tsm could decide to blow up their
whole roster
and start fresh if they don't know
bjergsen will have to navigate
already established relationships in an
entirely different way
relationships are often messy and
complicate
things and it could get a whole lot more
complicated between
these two given the new circumstances so
clearly
there is a lot on the line here but my
question is
does there actually need to be hear me
out for a second
people become coaches because they want
to
lead a team they want to influence its
direction they want to be a major part
of its success
which of those things did bjergsen not
already have
as a player he wasn't some sort of
frustrated rookie desperate to steer the
ship
bjergsen has two hands on the wheel
already and he
clearly has a pretty big say in who
comes
and who goes through the rotating tsm
roster door
when he became part owner of tsm last
year
it seemed like he had it all he had
influence over their business decisions
the team's direction and how they play
the game
so what is he really gaining here from
moving to a coaching position
careers friendships the team's success
there is a lot hanging in the balance
here for bjergsen
but perhaps the most delicate of them
all is his legacy
502 lcs games 10
lcs finals six lcs championships
and four-time lcs mvp bergson has been
building a
monumental legacy to himself brick
by hard-earned brick over the past seven
years there are times that it's taken a
knock but he's always
fought back and reached even greater
heights perhaps the
greatest height of all was his most
recent and now
final lcs win as a player in summer 2020
as the nexus falls tsm claim
lcs title number seven that right there
is the lasting memory that most fans
would have of him
if he bowed out of the competitive scene
forever but
now what if he coaches tsm off a cliff
what if reggie opens his checkbook to
bring in established stars and
give rookies a chance to help build
bjergsen's perfect team
and he blows it will history smile
kindly on him
i'm not trying to be a doomsayer here
it's easy to say that bjergsen's
reputation as the goat of
n a will forever be untarnished but how
much of that is based on the here and
now
fans can be fickle that's just the
nature of the game
bjergsen knows more than anyone this
won't be easy
he won't become the next coma overnight
and was the first to acknowledge the
challenge ahead in the announcement
video
i can't promise that i'm going to be the
perfect coach right away and
i'm going to make a lot of mistakes but
i hope that you guys know me and that
you know my mindset and that
every day i'm going to do my best to
improve even if i fail even if i make
mistakes
and i hope that in the long run i can be
the best
head coach that csm can ever find eve
bjergsen has rushed into this if the
team dynamics just
don't work if the players buckle under
the pressure
of not letting him down then his legacy
could be in real danger
it's a risk it could cement bjergsen in
the hall of fame
as not only one of the greatest players
to ever grace the north american stage
but one of its finest leaders and
strategists too
however those saying that this is a risk
worth taking
might be the wolves at the door if it
all goes wrong
but bjergsen didn't get to the level
he's at by not taking risks
he reached this level by daring when
others dared not
and perhaps this is his greatest gamble
yet
yeah maybe my ultimate dream is that tsm
win a single game at worlds
i'm kidding we did that in 2014 once
six years ago so it's all good
it's all good also shout out to jack my
good friend jack
he predicted that this would happen
about a week before the announcement i
don't know how he did it but yeah thanks
to him
bjergsen has two wheels on the hand two
wheels